welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and you now locked
into the channel where we break down all
the latest movies new game releases TV
shows and comic books with the release
of the second episode of Star Wars the
Mandalorian it's time to go back to a
long time ago in a galaxy far far away
and discuss everything that you need to
know about the show there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to watch episode 2 yet and don't
want to know what happens then I highly
suggest that you turn off now if you
enjoy the video then make sure you
subscribe to the channel to keep up to
date with breakdowns on the show episode
by episode I have spoken without the way
I just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into our
breakdown of the Mandalorian okay so
before we get into the episode itself
there's actually a really interesting
development that dropped earlier this
week in an interview with Pedro Pascal
Pascal stated that the Mandalorians real
name is din Joran and he mustn't have
got their din warned in the left at all
from Mickey Mouse and not to spoil his
stuff cuz I'm guessing he's gonna be mad
anyway just thought I'd dropped this in
the video early on in case I referred to
him as that and people don't know what
I'm talking about
anyway episode 2 picks up in the
aftermath of episode one's big
cliffhanger where did John came face to
face with a baby from the same species
as Yoda this is apparently a dangerous
and powerful asset and trying to take it
back to the client isn't an easy task as
we see throughout the episode last time
I said that I believe that this creature
would be extremely force sensitive which
in a time where there are little to no
Jedi outside of the Skywalker's would
make it an extremely valuable thing to
possess episode 2 name the child the
even though it's 50 years old
picks up immediately where we left off
mando protecting the baby is clearly
going to be the main driving force of
the season and whilst those who may be
let down by this expecting a story about
the titular character traversing the
galaxy for bounties actually think it's
the smart move to take to make us care
about a character that we know very
little about this episode is very short
but sweet and though it feels like
filler on the whole if you were to look
at the plot from a top-level view this
is still engaging as once again
absolutely nails the old atmosphere of
Star Wars
I'll talk about my general thoughts on
it later but it's still so well
presented that was brought instantly
back in from the atmospheric and slow
opening stroll after fighting off some
bounty hunters who want the baby more
than fans want a good episode 9 mando is
wounded and needs to heal himself the
aforementioned bowel shows that dihn is
an expert in all combat including melee
weapons and blasters and he makes sure
work of the creatures that look like
they come from the same species as
Bosque he starts off pretty vulnerable
and it's actually refreshing to see a
wounded man in these situations Liliana
tries to help him and say what you want
about Star Wars they always did manage
to bring cute elements into it yes I
actually liked the Ewoks mando pushes
him off and there are very minor hints
here that there's more to the baby than
meets the eye which I'll get into later
in the recap now what this does really
well is that it sets the tone for the
show going forward there are lots of
themes going on here but what we're
going to be dealing with going ahead is
someone who had their life ripped away
from them as a child aka the Mandalorian
trying to bring peace to another young
thing that could potentially have theirs
taken - though this episode isn't that
fulfilling on the whole it definitely is
intriguing and I must admit that the
questions that I have about the series
are quite a big driving force for me
wanting to push ahead as a viewer even
if I found this one a bit hit and miss
upon arriving back at his ship he
discovers that G hours have been
dismantling it for parts and before you
can say my clunky he takes out a lot of
them in quick fashion with a sniper
rifle this roadblock like the majority
of the episode feels like a diversion
taking us away from the main driving
force of the narrative but that doesn't
mean it's not thrilling mando has to set
off to stop a sand crawler from getting
away with the rest of his ride and this
is where the episode really picks up
this segment kind of feels like a
live-action version of the battlefront
games and all the best ways you can
imagine and watching him clamber up the
hulking machine reminded me a bit of
Luke in the Empire Strikes Back taking
on the outer walkers is it out out
walkers or is it 8080 leave it in the
comments below there's a nice little
reference to Indiana Jones in the Last
Crusade with mando almost being taken
out by a rock and we've never actually
seen a sand crawler up this close before
with it being used as a location in
itself rather than just a vehicle bat
banning his way at the side he's stunned
and sent crashing to the ground and left
to get back to the razor's crest to see
if he can get off world when it seems
like all hope is lost mando remembers
that he has in her eye on this planet
and watching him traverse the silhouette
of the sense that reminds you of just
how much Disney are really putting into
this production mando makes it too cool
who I only recently just discovered was
voiced by Nick Nolte and I must say
there's a resemblance there and they
serve to negotiate with the towers we
get more rocky music and also get to see
how cute baby otter is I don't know if
they're intentionally aping Mowgli from
the gremlins but there's some
similarities that make you just go
anyway after asking for his armor back
and almost turning the jours into the
Star Wars version of the Human Torch
they say that they want the egg and
drive him to this planets big monster I
love how every planet has their own
creatures on it and watching man no go
head to head with the mud horn is
brilliant even if it amounts to little
more than a set-piece mando doesn't do
well in the fight and he bombs worse
than solos box office which is where we
get our fan theory from last time
confirmed with baby Yoda showing that he
is able to use the force and it lifts
the creature into the air allowing Dean
jarring to kill it retrieving the egg in
the process now we know for definite
that the baby is indeed strong in the
force and if the other creatures of the
race that possess these powers such as
Yoda and Y at all are anything to go by
and this will be a powerful Jedi
shouldn't make it past the age of 700 or
whenever it's in high school Yoda had
four million midi-chlorians in him which
is near unprecedented and that's how he
was so powerful so potentially even if
this baby has half of that it will still
be extremely strong neither man doe or
alien McNulty understand what the baby
did which to me cements that after order
66 in Revenge of the Sith the very
mention of Jedi became relegated with
many not even knowing what the force is
this is why Han Solo seems so unsure of
it in a new hope and it does seem like
since the fall of the empire that again
and those with mystical powers have
faded back into obscurity anyway man no
returns the egg to the towers so they
can get some of that sweet crack I mean
honey
I mean egg and together with cool they
returned to the ship and fix it up man
no offers cool a position but he refuses
just wanting to go back to having peace
in his Valley he has spoken I'm sorry
that now I have spoken joke that I've
just rinsed throughout this entire video
is terrible please don't unsubscribe
anyway the episode ends with the
mandalorian flying back to the client to
potentially return the child now you
don't have to have the prophecy powers
of a Jedi to realize that this probably
won't happen and I imagine that when
mando gets back to the bounty holder and
he learns of what he intends to do which
is either experiment on the child or use
it as a weapon that mando will have
second thoughts I mean look at that baby
how could you hand it over to its death
this will likely put mando himself in
the crosshairs and he may be exiled from
the guild for breaking their rules and
in doing so hath to fend for himself
good thing he's got a baby beside him
that can move a freight train with their
mind and I can see these two teaming up
to take down all of the scum and
villainy that there are in the universe
we do know from the synopsis of next
time that mando will be meeting with the
Klein at least in the episode and I
definitely think that the situation will
go Bank the pudhu before gets any better
but what did I think of this episode
overall well after a really brilliant
season premiere this feels like a slight
step back and in the end it doesn't
amount to much more than filler at just
half an hour as well it feels like in a
necessary addition that does very little
to advance the plot in any major ways
did I hate though absolutely not and I
love coming back to this world for the
second time this week again this feels
like the true Star Wars vision that we
should be getting and therefore it's
hard to ding the episode for anything
more than it was just okay I think if
Disney had a followed the Netflix model
and they dropped all the shows in one go
then this wouldn't be getting as panned
as it is online but we have to take it
in the form that we got it with the next
episode now a week away I can't help but
feel slightly underwhelmed by it and
it's difficult to really critique this
in a negative way when it did absolutely
nothing wrong but also didn't really
excel in any way either if you watch my
last breakdown and review of the show
and huge thank you to everyone who
checked it out then you'll know that I
gave it a really high score with its
ceiling and impressive 9 out of 10
however because of that I have to judge
this episode to the same school and you
twin not really being as brilliant as
that first
entry was it's obviously going to suffer
slightly again I have to reiterate that
this isn't me slamming the show and even
these last two parts are better than the
last Jedi however I have to be honest
with myself and you guys watching this
and give it a fair score in my opinion
that's why the Mandalorian episode 2
gets a 7 out of 10
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the second episode as well
as what your theories are for the future
make sure you leave them in the comment
section below because I'd love to read
them and if you enjoy this video then
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you stay locked at the channel for
breakdowns of every episode as they're
released if you want to watch us discuss
more of the series that make sure you
check out our full breakdown of the
first episode which would be linked at
the end we go over everything that you
need to know about it all of the Easter
eggs are more so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want something else
to watch after this if you want to come
chat to me after the video then make
sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey or head over to my
discord server which you'd be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully I
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of the marble
phase 3 part 1 boxer on blu-ray which
contains Civil War Doctor Strange
homecoming Ragnarok and more and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is like the video make sure that
you subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on the mandalorian in the
comment section below the winners gonna
be chosen today on the 15th of November
and the Cell be shipped out from then to
ever get surprised it's the best of luck
to everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
you